- So Devin Nunes is back in the news.
We learned that in the waning
days of the Trump presidency,
the Department of
Justice, led by Bill Barr,
issued a subpoena against
Twitter to unmask the identity
of the person that was running
a parody Devin Nunes
account called NunezAlt.
Now, the Department of Justice
said that this was related
to prosecuting potential
threats against the congressmen.
Whereas Twitter pushed back.
They filed a motion to quash
to prevent the subpoena
from going forward and
asked for verification
of these supposed threats,
which the Department of Justice apparently
was not able to provide.
It's good that Twitter pushed back
because this was clearly protected
First Amendment activity,
and apparently the Department of Justice
dropped the subpoena
after Biden was elected.
So we're not gonna see Twitter in court,
but hopefully we'll see
some penalties for the AUSA
that actually filed this subpoena
because this is nonsense.